hey pop mmm
ask you a question how come you never
liked me like you what law is there say
I got to like you no all right then
don't you eat every day answer me when I
talk to you don't you eat every day yeah
as long as you in my house
you put a cell on the end of it when you
talk to me yes sir you eat everyday yes
sir got a roof over your head yes sir I
clothes on your back yes sir why you
think that is cuz he hell I know it's
cuz of me but why do you think that is
cuz you like me like you I go out of
here every morning I'd bust my butt cuz
I like you're about the biggest fool a
bass or a man is supposed to take care
of his family
you live in my house fill your belly
with my food
put your behind on my bed because you're
my son it's my duty to take care of you
I hope on sibility to you I ain't got to
like you now I don't give you everything
I got to give you I give you your life
me and your mama work that out between
us and liking your black ass wasn't part
of the bargain now don't you go through
life worrying about whether somebody
like you or not
you best be making sure that they're
doing right by you you understand what
I'm saying
everything that boy do he do for you
it's not easy for me to admit that I've
been standing in the same place for 18
years understanding with you
I gave 18 years of my life to stand in
the same spot as you
you